in the second geithner video I lay out a
scenario where a bank could let me draw
its balance sheet let's say that's not
how I wanted to do it let's say that
this is a bank it's holding let me draw
its assets and liabilities so it's
holding some toxic asset a right here
now this for that could be the bank's
equity that's its liabilities and this
is the other assets for the bank so it
can hold some toxic asset a and we laid
out a scenario where what the bank could
do right now it's a hundred percent
exposure today what I could do is it
could take a little bit of cash lend it
to another party let's say it could lend
it to a hedge fund so this becomes a
loan to the hedge fund right so now the
book the hedge fund owes this money to
our bank and it now has the cash on its
balance sheet all right so this would
now instead of being cash it'll be it'll
be called loan loan to hedge fund now
this is the hedge funds balance sheet
its liability is loan from bank and now
it has this cash and then it could use
this cash to invest in this in
essentially the legacy loans program the
the public private investor legacy loans
program that Geithner talks about and if
they did this they could take this let's
say this was $7
they could take the $7 contribute it to
the equity in the program the Treasury
would contribute another $7 the Fed
would contribute $84 and then they would
have $100 and I know this is kind of
messy but they would have $100 that they
can then use to go buy these assets
right and the net effect of this is is
that a bank this bank went from having a
hundred percent exposure to this toxic
asset to having only $7 exposure through
this loan to this hedge fund or the
special purpose entity or whatever you
want to call it and I got a couple of
emails and even from some colleagues say
well you know is this really
this really be done and you know my my
my kind of knee-jerk reaction was well
if this can't be done they'll figure out
a way to do it because there's billions
of dollars of stakes and and really the
incentive here is structured to do it
and frankly the government probably
wants them to do it because on some
level even though this would be a
massive transfer of exposure and wealth
from taxpayers from the banks from the
taxpayers to the banks it would on some
level solve the problem and if people
really aren't aware of it everyone will
be happy about it because you know all
of these banks Citibank and Bank of
America will just survive and you know
they they can just kind of say that all
all's well so what I wanted to do is
just to answer those questions get a
little bit particular about the wording
and I got an email Leigh Logan actually
emailed me and she she highlighted one
clause in the legacy loans term shieff
that seems to address what I talked
about in that in that second video there
and it says private this is from the
legacy loans term sheet it says private
investors may not participate in any ppi
F so this is that you know private
public investment fund that purchases
assets from sellers that are affiliates
affiliates of such investors or that
represent 10% or more of the aggregate
private capital in the PPI F so a
question is what's an affiliate and then
I looked up but you know in the
Securities Exchange Act of 1934 and
there are multiple definitions but this
is probably the best one is that you
know the term affiliate means any
company that controls is controlled by
or as an or is under common control with
another company and that scenario that I
just outlined this Bank really doesn't
control this hedge fund right they just
essentially gave them a loan with very
little stipulations on it and then the
hedge fund can go do it but you could
say oh well you know there's nothing
that this bank could do there's nothing
that this bank could do to force this
hedge fund to buy these assets so maybe
this plan won't work and another thing
is you know what's the definition of the
private capital right you also can't
represent ten percent more of the
aggregate private capital frankly when I
think of private capital I think more in
terms
equity investments but maybe the
definition of private capital also
includes debt investments although I
doubt it
so in this video I want to lay out a
scenario that essentially they can do
the same thing economically and in fact
incent the exact behavior that they want
and the other parties without being in
any way an affiliate of the counterparty
and in no way giving capital directly to
them so what bank a could do instead let
me redraw it actually not Bank a the
bank that's holding toxic asset a I'm
afraid this is what I thought of after
kind of thinking about it for about five
or ten minutes you could imagine what
the banks will come up with when they
have billions of dollars in careers on
the stake online so if you have a
scenario where you have this toxic asset
a and you economically want to do what I
described but you just wanted you don't
want to be an affiliate and you don't
want to give the appearance of self
dealing what you do is you sell credit
defaults on a that become super cheap so
you have essentially seven dollar
exposure of credit defaults what I mean
let me do it this way so what you do is
you sell credit default swaps so let's
say you sell $7 of exposure so your
liability right here is a $7 c.d.s
exposure and I'll go over the economics
of how this works in a second and you
sell you actually get some some an
income stream and you wouldn't even be
accounted this way you normally just
have to if you're insuring $7 worth of
credit default swaps your liability
isn't $7 it's you know you you do the
probability to default and all of that
so your liability will probably be I
don't know $1 whatever it is and you get
some income stream for it but the the
general notion is is that you sell sell
credit default swaps on this toxic asset
on a on a for really cheap for really
cheap and just so you know what a credit
default swap is I've made a couple of
videos on it is essentially an insurance
policy on a loan or on a company and if
that company or this loan defaults you
say that you're going to pay up
essentially the insurance amount so what
you do is you sell
seven dollars seven dollars of credit
default swaps on a and just so you know
most of these toxic assets that these
banks hold these are assets that they
were the originators for and so they're
very particular to the individual banks
so a bank can definitely say I'm selling
a credit default swap on a and they know
that in the end when I kind of outlined
this whole thing they'll be the main
beneficiary of it so if you sell seven
dollars credit default swaps on a what
would I do
well I'm a hedge fund what I do is I buy
those credit defaults for really cheap
and then I invest in the towel fright so
let's say I'm a hedge fund and I have
two things I have a seven seven dollar
investment in the in the towel and the
tie and sorry that in this Geithner plan
investment and then I also have this
credit default swap this insurance
contract and just so you know you pay a
few you know depending on the price you
pay a certain amount every year but the
key here is that this Bank could sell it
if they wanted to for almost free right
they can essentially give away these
credit default swaps so if that Bank did
it then if the hedge funds assets would
have the $7 an investment in this
Geithner program and then it'll have $7
seven dollars of credit default swap
protection now what happens to this
hedge fund in the world where asset a is
worth a lot they get all of the upside
through their investment in the Geithner
plan right that seven dollar investment
gets levered to $100 right and they go
let me actually do draw that again so
that seven dollar investment is here
seven dollars of capital seven dollars
from the Treasury you have eighty six
dollars from the Fed and they use this
to give the cash here and then that goes
back here and you're holding toxic asset
a now if toxic asset a ends up being
worth a lot of money then this hedge
fund then this is worth a lot and this
is worth nothing and that's okay because
the hedge fund essentially paid nothing
for it or paid next to nothing for
and in which in which case you know and
everyone kind of works out well in that
scenario on the other hand let's say
that this thing is worth zero right
let's say that this thing defaults if
that thing default then this investment
is worth zero but guess what the hedge
fund had an insurance policy where this
guy was a counterparty so he says hey
this thing here defaulted I'm gonna get
claim my insurance policy so this guy is
gonna have to send him seven dollars so
it's economically the exact same thing
that I outlined in the Geithner 2 video
but in this situation these guys it's
almost an arm's length transaction but
this Bank can make that behavior happen
by essentially going into the market and
selling credit default swaps for this
exact asset for really really cheap and
this is just the first way I thought
about it there's other ways you could do
it if you have enough of if you're just
a separate hedge fund and you own enough
of this the shares in a bank let's say
you owned all of the shares in the bank
or a good percentage of the shares in
the bank then you would also have an
incentive to go out there and buy the to
use the Geithner plan and lever up and
buy these assets another thing is I
don't want to get too technical if you
kind of hold one of the fulcrum pieces
of debt the pieces of debt that are
trading in a discount because you're
afraid that this bank is going to fail
if you hold a bunch of though those
assets you still would want to
participate in the Geithner plan and
funnel money and use the government
money to essentially buy this asset a I
mean the general theme here is if you
have two people right if these are this
is the private world and you have a
scenario where person a if a transaction
can make a hundred dollars or he gets
rid of a hundred dollars of exposure and
person B person B essentially has a
potential loss of minus seven dollars of
exposure there's a net transfer of
wealth here right
you went from a hundred dollars of
exposure to to seven dollars of exposure
for this guy right so someone is
offloading the 93 dollars of exposure to
this stuff and that's the government and
the government's only taking the
downside so this is a huge subsidy of
exposure it depends what these are
really worth if these things if this
thing is really worth thirty
and it's a $63 exposure but anytime you
have this the private sector is going to
figure out a way it's going to figure
out a way to make the subsidy happen and
everything I'm outlined so far is if a
is the bank that has 100% exposure all
they have to do is through whatever you
know backdoor scheme or financial
product or insurance or whatever they
want to do or loans that have you know
very little stipulations on it they just
have to give this guy essentially seven
dollars of compensation somehow that's
you know gets around the government
rules and then this transaction will
occur and I hope it doesn't occur and
it's very possible it won't because
maybe I'm missing something here but I'm
just saying that if you know everything
I understand about the Geithner plan is
is if there's a huge incentive for this
to occur and this is frankly the only
reason why the plan would work because
as I outlined in the other videos for a
private investor who's not incented in
this way the put option that the
government is giving them still is not
enough of a rationale to go from paying
$30 for an asset to going to pay $60 an
asset so it won't work if this behavior
doesn't occur the only way that the plan
quote unquote will work and people will
overpay for the assets is if you have
this type of action going on